kamala hey already really come on like do i have
to figure out my whole future before launchers
maybe they're right i spend too much time
and fantasy land that is not to you
it's not really the brown girls
from jersey city you save the world
that's a fantasy too
i'm a superhero
Welcome back everyone this will be my miss marvel
trailer video marvel released the first official
trailer they've obviously changed a bunch about
her character so i'll explain what's going on with
her powers and what her new backstory is going
to be how it's going to connect with the marvel
phase 4 movies and also with all the young
avengers stuff that they're putting together
in the background with these marvel disney plus
series and characters if you're brand new to the
channel i will be doing videos for the episodes
be sure to subscribe to get everything they're
going to be dropping episodes starting on june 8th
and a lot of you have actually correctly guessed
that that will overlap with the obi-wan kenobi
episodes so when we get closer to that and we
actually learn more about what the actual obi-wan
kenobi schedule is going to be then i'll talk more
about how my videos are going to work for the
most part i'll probably do obi-wan kenobi videos
then i'll do my miss marvel videos but most of you
are probably familiar at least a little bit with
kamala khan from the comics so miss marvel kamala
khan relatively new character in the last 10 years
or so she's just the newest character to use the
miss marvel name but the comic book origin story
very different from the mcu backstory so a lot of
you asking lots of inhumans questions because in
the comics miss marvel kamala khan is an inhuman
but we don't have inhumans in the mcu at least yet
so that's part of the reason why they changed her
origin story a little bit marvel also said that
they specifically changed her powers to make them
more similar to captain marvel and monica rambeau
spectrum powers or photon whichever name they go
with for monica rambeau's superhero name when she
comes back in the marvel's movie but the miss
marvel series is also meant to get miss marvel
ready for captain marvel 2 the marvels movie in
the title the marvels as in plural marvels is a
play on all their comic book names being based
on captain marvel even though during the movie
they'll probably use monica rambeau's photon or
spectrum name she is actually the original female
version of captain marvel in the comics she used
the captain marvel name a long time before carol
danvers did there's actually a big easter egg
for that during the dr strange 2 multiverse of
madness trailer video so you've all been wondering
about this mystery character that this variant of
scarlet witch's fighting like this is not our main
mcu scarlet witch who's fighting this character
here but she is fighting a captain marvel variant
who is actually maria rambeau, monica rambeau's
mother from an alternate universe where she was
the test pilot on the day the captain marvel got
her powers so maria rambeau got powers in that
reality and is sort of a wink at the idea that
monica rambeau is the original female captain
marvel even though in this case it's her mother
for those of you that are still hoping to see
inhumans show up in the mcu doctor strange too
would be the place for that to happen there are a
lot of rumors that we might see a variant to black
bolt show up from the inhumans tv show i don't
know if that's true it's just a rumor but that
would be the place for it to happen if we're doing
so many variants of so many different versions of
characters from the fox marvel movies like we
have fantastic four fox marvel characters that
are supposed to show up we also have a variant of
patrick stewart's professor x from those original
fox x-men movies if you don't know anything about
kamala khan she is basically a pakistani american
girl from jersey city which is on the other side
of new york city from spider-man who's over in
queens i believe she's actually marvel's first
on-screen desi superhero that they've done in the
mcu the way they explained her backstory in the
comics is that she's an inhuman and this terrigen
bomb of terrigen mist goes off in new york city
during this big comic book event it activates
her inhuman powers and she basically gains the
power to embigan herself that's just the way they
play it in the comics what she's actually doing
though the way her powers work is she actually
pulls energy from her future self to make herself
bigger change her body size and strengthen herself
you see them using this special bracelet with
the energy powers to do versions of that like
a couple of the takedowns that she has during
this trailer where she puts both of her fists
together and smashes them down that is out of
the comics it's just that they're using the green
lantern construct explainer for this with the
energy her powers on the show will come from the
special bracelet and because they wanted to have
similar powers to captain marvel monica rambeau
i'm assuming that the bracelet she finds in her
attic is either a cree or a skrull artifact from
some point in ancient history like it got left
on earth a long time ago and just wound up in her
family and for whatever reason they just forgot
about it or it only works for her for some reason
the whole idea with her character though is
that she's basically like an avengers fan girl
who writes her own avengers fan fiction that's why
they're using all the animation in the comic book
thought bubbles like she's imagining things while
she's sitting in the middle of class or while
she's having meetings with other administrators
all these drawings in her journal it's all just
stuff from the comics like before she became
captain marvel she writes all these stories
about her having adventures with the avengers
captain marvel's just her favorite character
so like in the middle of the trailer here where
she's daydreaming they have the comic book thought
bubble that turns into the marvel logo but she's
been doodling the wasp in ant-man characters like
you see her drawing a scene with ant-man it seems
like she's in the middle of history class if you
look at her textbook it has the egyptian artifacts
and symbols on it that's a bit of a sly wink at
moon knight because miss marvel is the next marvel
series after moon knight even though there's not
really a huge connection between their characters
most of the characters that she runs into in her
high school here are just regular high school kids
like not a lot of them have superpowers it's kind
of like spider-man when he was at midtown high
during the early spider-man homecoming trilogy
she's a couple years younger than spider-man like
spider-man literally is getting ready to graduate
although it's a bit of a tricky situation because
of the way that everybody just forgot about him
that's why he has to get his ged because he can't
graduate from midtown high because they don't
have any records of him ever attending but in the
next couple years if they do a spider-man college
trilogy like starting in spider-man 4 kamala khan
could theoretically attend the same college with
spider-man eventually she's only a couple years
younger so like if they get a season 2 she'll
still be in high school when that happens you
notice the school kids make fun of her avengers
t-shirt like she is an avengers fan girl as i said
but it's the wasp captain marvel and valkyrie on
the shirt i'm assuming that this series takes
place at some point close to when hawkeye takes
place but not during the winter holiday like you
don't see it snowing anywhere in the footage here
we're now into like the year after avengers end
game like things are slowly pushing forward in
the timeline you see the captain marvel halloween
costume that she winds up using later after she
gets the bracelet that gives her the powers in
the original comic book origin story she starts
out like right after she gets her powers with the
terrigen miss she wears one of the older versions
of captain marvel's costume with the sash but
eventually winds up making her own version
of a miss marvel costume that looks like this one
this scene of her sitting on top of the street
light looking out over the river at manhattan
is actually right out of the comic books this
is a comic book panel i'm assuming this happens a
little bit later in the run of the series because
she's wearing the full comic book costume like
she's upgraded from the halloween costume the
person that she spends all this time talking to
and all these scenes this boy here is bruno he's
also right out of the comics he's sort of like
her best friend that's sort of like the friend
zone trope where he eventually winds up becoming
her boyfriend it's a very common trope of teenage
high school series where like two people are
best friends and they don't realize that they're
totally into each other till much later all these
scenes of her in the captain marvel costume is her
just basically daydreaming herself being a version
of captain marvel until she gets the actual powers
and then tries to do it for real causing all the
disasters you would expect a teenager to cause
when they get special powers like this it was the
same thing during spider-man homecoming like he
gets the upgraded stark tech suit winds up causing
almost as much collateral damage as the villain's
cause it would not be a spider-man or a marvel
story if spider-man did not cause a lot of the
problems that he winds up having to solve just
look at what happened during spider-man no way
home with doctor strange's spell but i don't
know if brie larson herself is actually going
to cameo during the series my assumption right
now is that they'll have a post-credit scene
like monica rambeau's post-credit scene during
wandavision so that was meant to be sort of a
teaser for captain marvel 2 the marvels maybe also
a little bit for secret invasion something similar
will probably happen with ms marvel at the end of
the miss marvel series that will help bring her to
what's going on with captain marvel during the
events of captain marvel 2. they give you a couple
hints about what's going on with the villains they
don't really show you too much of the villains but
they're actually two different villain groups
that they're supposed to use on the series
this group of black ops armored soldiers seem
like they're connected to this organization called
nice n-i-c-e they're not from the comics but
they're basically like an mcu version of ice
and if you're not familiar with that that's
actually immigration customs and enforcement
it sounds like they're going to be a lot like the
grc organization from falcon and winter soldier
but mostly for immigration inside the united
states like the global repatriation committee
trying to send all the people who moved from
other countries after the snap back to where
they came from they were super antagonistic
during the falcon and winter soldier series
so nice is kind of giving off that same vibe the
other super villain group i think is going to be
a little bit more of a legit super villain group
that you would expect they're called clandestine
they're pretty obscure but they descend from
an actual legit gin inside the mcu they become
this family of really powerful magic users
and some of the family members get powers
this character here that she's fighting
using her powers with the red mask is a
version of red dagger from the comics he might
be connected to that clandestine organization
the way they're using him here he might wind
up being like a mid boss for her to take down
in the actual main villain final boss will be
someone from higher up in that organization
i know you're all asking about young avengers
crossover because she does seem like core young
avengers material just based on the vibe of the
character here in the trailer if they actually do
wind up doing a young avengers project in the mcu
which it seems like they plan on doing long term
eventually it probably wouldn't happen until
after they introduced all the mains and that
wouldn't be till after ant-man 3. that comes out
after captain marvel 2 during next summer whatever
young avengers easter eggs we see during the miss
marvel episodes i'll just include those in my
videos for them if you spotted any easter eggs
in the trailer that i didn't talk about during
the video or you have any questions about kamala
khan's miss marvel character in the mcu just leave
them in the comments while you wait for everything
everyone click here for my brand new spider man
no way home deleted scenes video and click here
for my brand new marvel moon knight trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!